I mean whatever and he's gonna start
shooting they all want what you've got
and they'll kill each and every one of
us until they get it when we turn with
us in the corner all I need to bring
today I'm 30 years old
I wear a Hawaiian shirt for my boyfriend
dumped me a text
let's set it on fire we just want to
talk about drew Thayer he's your
boyfriend right drew I'm sorry what I
know you're a spy
it's a long story that'll explain
everything 24:00 head some bad people
are after me another after you if we
don't deliver this package you've had a
lot of people are gonna die
you want to die having never been to
Europe or do you want to go to Europe
and die having been to Europe why are
those my only two options
terrorist group is buying a series of
assassinations a lot of innocent people
are gonna die unless you're something
real and I honestly think I'm in shock
Helen you are incredible and I want you
to own it
[Applause]
[Music]
you have a real instinct for this Scylla
okay without you and then what you're
the boss and yet you have not sacrificed
one ounce of femininity that is the
Beyonce of the government
[Music]